I am stilling a little bit speechless at
what we just saw on this episode of dudy
welcome to the new world of bad bunnies
rocket money honey rmy ready for my
colonoscopy lots of fiction happening in
the movie
yeah I'm I'm excited we slap our hand
where
we I can't hear you I can barely hear
you sitting in this room world inside
your because I don't scream well they're
not going to hear that either I'm not
screaming what is
that would you like to repeat everything
that you just said so that everyone can
hear what you I think everybody heard it
fine well I'll tell you what everyone's
hearing right now it's us me saying hey
Chad let's have a good show no one's
listening right now it's just me let's
have a good show Chad welcome to dudy
you know what welcome all it is a dudy
full day happy New Year I am your
rainning
defending Undisputed dudy episode
champion in the middle of an incredible
rain Chad spanning uh two calendar years
at this point 2023 and 2024 my name is
Will Sasso you know I'm Chad culin and I
will be wearing that belt by the end of
this year I think the smart sooner than
that like I said earlier namely last
week or the week before on the dudes
dudes evening special the smart booking
says let's keep strap you know on Sasso
through next dude's evening get Roman
Reigns thing going all right I'm Chad
culin I will be your champion in the
year 2024 this is of course dudy a
podcast created by controlled by written
by an artificial intelligence that has
access to all of Will and I's personal
data personal information and it tailors
the show to our sensibilities written by
an artificial intelligence as it says so
impersonal if I may we're talking about
our good pal D here yeah we're talking
about about we're talking about D yeah D
runs the Wheels of Steel Chad but like I
always like to say uh you and I we are
dudy we're a couple of couple of one two
dudes [__] around and uh that's to
my one two dudes what's up couple of one
two that's how I count one one two dude
yeah a couple of one two dudes onew dude
yeah um and uh you uh anyway with us as
always oh Jesus is uh we do the show
what the [__] ever it's yeah dudy does
what dudy does and we we need to uh
respect that but what what now now what
nothing we haven't even started this
[__] I
agree with us as always is
lul oh and he's happy to be back he's
happy to be back for a brand new year
he's got a little doggy smile from ear
to ear his uncle Chad won't give him a
kiss that's something that he miss oh oh
he's such a sweetie boy lulio how are
you how's it going I'm doing pretty good
it's a it's a new year isn't it yeah
it's a new year comes at 24 after 23 so
what can you tell us about what's been
going on in your new year the New Year
of oh my gosh you hear about this K
Williams he went on Club B sh uh shanon
Sharpie is a podcast and then he talk a
[__] on everybody is making a lot of
noise on the internet see LLY knows
what's going on listen to
podcast wow I didn't know
that oh he's such a sweetie boy always
swinging him around welcome to the 87th
episode of dudy and welcome to a brand
new year of humanity I've got so much
big [__] planned for 2024 your minds are
going to be blown and your lines are
going to be thrown down deep into the
hole and you might just get a glimpse of
what's down here first things first will
I really need to hear some of your
Jessie Ventura it's been too long so
we're kicking things off with a brand
new Jessie Ventura ad reads then we're
going to check on those beautiful
buttholes with colon boys and to round
out our first showback we're going to
find out what my little tiny Darlings
thought of the ironclaw in an allnew
edition of the Imp purest I'm so glad to
have you both back in the studio with me
let's show this year who's boss what do
you say I say [__] a d That's what I
say what do you say ch yeah I definitely
say uh 2024 will showed who boss we both
had our colonoscopies I'll tell you that
that's new for 24 having done that oh
you know what else is new for 24 I have
to mention it I've talked about this
before on the show because it is just I
mean my favorite series that I've been a
part of louder milk uh created by Bobby
Mort and executive produced and directed
uh uh by Peter fley we've also had Bob
Fairley come in and direct louder milk
starring Ron Livingston is uh on Netflix
uh now and it's spent some time in the
top top it dude congrats it's awesome
thank you very much I love this [__]
show I love uh the people that did the
show with us and I can't say enough
about it so if you if you would like to
see louder milk it's on Netflix it's a
comedy series about uh anyway go check
it out there's three seasons of it on
Netflix and uh we're all very proud of
the show I speak for everybody when I
say Enjoy that uh what's been going on
been doing some yoga how's your New Year
been going oh yoga's good dude yeah dude
well hold on dude let me tell you about
yoga brother and I'm not talking about
hero matsuda grabbing my toe pulling
back on my leg with his knee on it
snapping it in half saying don't come
back here dude but I came back dude
three months later after my leg was
healed dude then they smartened me up to
the business brother okay uh but yeah
that was all came from yoga just the
word
yoga I do a lot of tapping out in yoga I
used to oh really well how flexible are
you can you touch toes I'm at yes I can
touch my [__] toes all I couldn't for
a while oh sorry so yeah no I can do
most of the stuff uh in a you know in a
in a medium ass class I used to do a lot
of yoga so my most of my flexibility is
still there but me and my wonderful wife
Molly have been going to yoga what a
treat I am [__] super excited for
this new year same I'm super excited uh
for the new year of dudy and uh I'm
stoked for all of our pods Pals of dudy
who are along with us and this is it too
this is the the year of the alien ladies
and gentlemen what is what does that
mean we're going to see if I can alien
you see that [__] in Miami no what
happened to Miami look it up look up
Miami alien just Google that hey
everybody go head on over to the
internet uh internet.com check out check
out internet.com
Ty in Alien our good pal Chia here on
dude zfm typ in Miami alien hey Miami
alien alien Mall alien yeah 10,000 on
your fm dial it's dudy FM hey we got
ched culton in the uh in the studio hell
of a uh writer Producer rack on tour
podcaster
aliens aliens what's going on with the
aliens I think in Miami there was one in
a
mall there was one in a mall yeah
dude we both do Impressions and everyone
will understand what I mean by that
shortly anyway will your Jessie Ventura
tickles me where it counts your ability
to pick up on the subtleties of
intonation speech Rhythm and accent
combined with your phonetic flexibility
and comedic mimicry never failed to
deliver the illusion of sounding like a
different person and that's an
impression dude I put together some
brand new ad reads just so I could hear
you do what you do so well so why why
don't you tell me what this segment is
all right I will this is Jessie Ventura
ad reads begin all right Jessie Ventura
ad reads this is one of my favorites
dude me too man mua oi as they say in
Japan oh I know it's French um I sucked
at French in high school did you take
you took Spanish because you're here in
the United States see yep we take uh
French over there in Canada all
right hey speaking of uh Spanish you
know who lives down in the Baja it's
Jesse Ventura let me warm up my U let me
shape my vocal cords and uh pitch my
intonation as dudy says yeah he was
giving you a lot of real intricate
compliments very uh scientific breakdown
of what an impression actually is uh we
appreciate it here okay hey it's time oh
this is
interesting uh you know in the past when
we do uh dudy or the Jessie ventur ad
reads there's been a lot of Arby's in
there and stuff this Hostess dingdong
yeah we got some new [__] from 2004 here
we
go oh
god oh that wasn't performative I'm
sorry I coughed I'm trying to if that's
not performative you got to go to a
doctor immediately I just went to a
doctor we had colonos I
know and they went in the wrong hole hey
Chad hey cheers
it went up the wrong
hole okay a lot of mouth noises for us
just listening on our podcast app of
choice let's get into Jessie ventur here
we go it's 2024 and Rocket money is all
in on Bad
[Music]
Bunny what I don't know oh Christ okay
they're looking for someone
to God jeez all right they're looking
for someone to play Bad bunnies funny
buddy in a new Bad Bunny buddy comedy
called show me the rocket
money think you got what it
takes all you got to do is make a video
doing your best funny buddy while you
say hey Bad Bunny show me the rocket
money then put it on the internet and
don't forget the hashtag
# show me the rocket
[Applause]
money okay okay well let me tell you
about a funny buddy in 1984 the CIA
produced 10 episodes of a sitcom called
garbagio Jeff gold Bloom played Donnie
DCH a lonely sanitation worker who
accidentally finds a semiconscious alien
in a dumpster behind a pizza Hut so he
ew ew so he names the alien garbagio and
takes him in as a
roommate Danny deito was
garbagio all 10 episodes involved other
people nearly finding out that garbagio
is an alien forcing DCH to go to Great
Lengths to convince people that garbagio
is his cousin from Eastern Europe in the
finale garb reveals he's a scout for an
alien Army who's on its way to Earth to
exterminate the human race true all of
Garbo's lines included subliminal
neurolinguistic programming designed to
produce a mind control effect in the
viewing audience unfortunately no
network ever bought
garbagio okay there's a lot of that one
holy [__] so rocket money is all in on
Bad Bunny it's 2024 dude they're
producing it looks like a uh movie buddy
comedy and they're they're doing a
casting call via the Internet I guess
yeah go to the Internet make a video
Yeah show me the rocket
money Bad Bunny yeah it's hey Bad Bunny
show me the rocket money dude that's a
pretty good funny buddy maybe it's like
this it's more like this hey Bad Bunny
show me the rocket money that's pretty
good you I like I like the first reading
it was a little dry yeah Chad gross
don't burp on the show um and but the
the second one's good too but you could
go like that whole like he's playing a
straight man maybe bad Bunny's the funny
one bad bunny show me the rocket money
oh that's pretty good yeah cheers okay
here's another one uh rocket money and
Bad Bunny have done it
again welcome to the new world of bad
bunni's welcome to the new world of bad
bunnies rocket money honey
rumy a premixed cocktail from the number
one pop star in the world and the number
one money management app on your
phone bad Bunny's rocket money honey Ry
is the perfect blend of spiced Caribbean
rum raw Golden Honey and the from the
rocket money B
sanctuary in Sudbury
Ontario that's are there any P
sanctuaries there I have no idea I would
imagine maybe in the summer months those
bees would come out and just a splash of
diet
squirt and looks like what a a strange
drink okay bad bunnies rocket money
honey Romy coat your throat bad bunnies
rocket money honey rmy you do
who bad bunni's rocket money honey Ry
life moves fast we move
faster bad bunni's rocket bunny honey Ry
the difference is
obvious what is Happ I don't know bad
Bunny's rocket bunny honey Ry you had me
it's sustainably
sourced bad bunnies rocket money honey
Romy smooth
sips bad bunnies rocket money honey Ry
it's like Flavor in a drink sure yeah
bad Bunny's rocket money honey Ry don't
ever look back bad bad bunni's rocket
bunny honey Ry it wasn't your
fault that's the slogan for the drink it
wasn't your fault well let me tell you
about who was at fault Jeff gold bloom
all of garbagio focus
tests yield the same result people love
deito as garbagio but they didn't buy
gold Bloom as a sanitation worker the
CIA did some tests with Robert
guom as a replacement for gold Bloom
love gum you remember Benson yeah yeah
uh but nothing ever came of it the
project was shelv and it's rumored that
there are only three copies of the
series that exist on
VHS one stays in the Oval
Office Quinton Tarantino has one and
screens it for Leon Ardo DiCaprio on his
[Music]
birthday and the last copy was rumored
to have been buried with the late George
HW Bush but that's exactly what it is a
rumor Jerry Seinfeld has
it do know want to see garbagio so bad
oh God Jeff gold and Danny DeVito and
DeVito is an alien oh [__] man I like it
I like it so far all right here's a is
this all right here's the last
one get your jogging shoes on because
it's almost time for the rocket money
Bad Bunny Sunny
run join Bad Bunny for
a
Jesus join Bad Bunny for a
344 mile jog across the state of New
Mexico to participate simply download
the rocket Bad Bunny Sunny run app and
click the Run
button the Run begins at day break on
the first sunny day of spring the rocket
money Bad Bunny Sunny run begins in
Springfield Arizona near the Mexico
border you'll run east across the scenic
state of New Mexico and cross the finish
line that evening in mu shoe Texas near
the New Mex what they do this in one day
I [__] guess okay mule Sho is also
near the Mexico border ew gross he's
coughing [__] I'm laughing sometimes I
cough when I laugh sometimes you cough
when you laugh other times you pretend
according to this guy he thinks I'm
performative coughing all the time
you've cough three times in this show by
my count
sorry near the New Mexico border you'll
receive fluids and your cell phone will
be returned to you in time to see Bad
Bunny take the stage for the final
performance perance at the rocket money
Bad Bunny Sunny Run fun in the sun
Festival well let me tell you about a
festival in 1990 Corporal Dean
Festival a high ranking Army
intelligence officer attempted to revive
project
garbagio with a brand new reboot of the
series Festival took certain liberties
with the underlying creative material
changing the premise from a garbage man
finding an alien in Dum in a dumpster to
two garbage men brothers finding the
body of an assassinated politician in a
garbage can Festival tried but was
unable to convince the brass to bankroll
the project even though he had real life
Brothers Charlie Sheen and amelo esz
attached to star in it frustrated with
the lack of recognition he felt his work
deserved Festival faked his own
death underwent extensive plastic
surgery and moved to Hollywood where he
produced garbagio as a movie with a new
title Men at Work oh [__] dude I love
that movie I didn't know that's how it
got made now why don't you tell me why
there was never a sequel all right
wasn't not bad huh I think there was a
sequel moving on yeah minute work too I
think so all right well anyway there it
is I have entered into an astonishing
partnership with rocket money dude you
remember how I used to be addicted to
Pokémon go yes I do I used to literally
go out to the pier every night from
about 8:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m. marching up
and down at looking for my man yeah uh
well when you were at that level of
addiction like I was you are not just
putting money into Pokémon go you're
buying third party apps that allow you
to track various Pokemon nests around
the city and I just downloaded rocket
money last week on my phone and found
out I'd been paying $5 a month into an
app that I haven't used for four years
to track Pokemon and it made it very
simple to click it off cancel that
subscription in one click and uh so now
I'm not hemorrhaging money into the void
anymore rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower bills
rocket money has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of
$720 a year with over $500 million in
cancel subscriptions stop wasting money
on things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket money.com dudy that's rocket
money.com dudy rocket
money.com dudy dudy is engaged in an
astonishing partnership with factor it's
a brand New Year uh you know a lot of
people have health goals I know I know
that we do if you're living your life
right you're probably gearing up for
summer swimsuit season because Summer
always comes after uh spring and uh
spring comes after winter so with uh
with your busy year arriving you might
be looking for wholesome convenient
meals for jam-packed days Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with Chef
prepared dietician approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you'll save time you'll eat well and
stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle if you're too busy uh to cook
you know with all this stuff that's
going on at the beginning of the year
you're trying to jump start it but you
want to make sure that you're eating
well you use Factor you skip the extra
trip to the grocery store no one wants
to do that The Chopping pre prepping and
cleaning up and all that thing you know
you sometimes you don't have time for
that stuff you still get the flavor you
get the nutritional quality you need
Factor's fresh never fro meals are ready
in Just 2 minutes so all you have to do
is heat and enjoy and get on with your
New Year head to factor meals.com dudy
50 and use code dudy 50 to get 50% off
that's code dudy 5050 at Factor
meals.com dud Z50 to get 50%
off uh rocket money Bad Bunny sunny
sunny runny
[__] 355 M run across New Mex like
that you start in Arizona you cross the
border you run clear across New Mexico
to muo Texas yeah well [__] [__] muo
Texas was one of the places I was
looking to buy a [__] Ranch but there
just ain't a whole lot of tell you what
they don't got a lot of there they don't
got a lot of [__] deer what they do
got is a lot of [__] boar and I'm not
sitting up in a [__] deer stand to
shoot a [__] boar chomping away at my
[__] Deer Lick these are wrestling
Impressions why not take a trip to dudy
store.com and pick up a dudy logo
t-shirt or perhaps a good job boner mug
to keep your brushes in while you're
finishing up that painting Bradley
Cooper commissioned from you to hang
over his bed you know the one I'm
talking about the nud still life of him
eating an onion in front of a creosote
Bush growing out of his penis yes it was
a strange request but he paid you
$75,000 and made you sign an NDA so you
can never talk about it but you're
making a video about the whole thing and
if he ever wrongs you that video goes to
every newspaper in America and he knows
it oh I almost forgot to mention Tom
Hayne has a new movie coming out and he
sent us a trailer let's take a peek holy
[__] when my uncle died he left me this
25,000 ft Mansion but it came with one
condition I had to live in it and take
care of the 386 cats he left behind and
I'll be the first one to admit I was
going to sell the place and give the
cats to local children on Christmas day
but after living here for a few weeks I
know each one of these cats by their
personalities and smell Stephie likes to
nap in a shoe box Cameron only eats
pudding pops tip tip can read Mr Nichols
likes to be combed Princessa looks out
the fourth floor stained glass window to
watch the world go by Marza pan plays
the banjo Harley lost his tail at Birth
peanut loves to play with bubbles button
drinks human blood do you understand
what I'm saying this is my house and
these are my cats so unless you want to
help me clean out their [__] boxes I
can't marry you
[Laughter]
Jennifer house cats he knows them by
their spell kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty kitty kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty
wow okay Tom Hayne busiest man in
Hollywood this guy's kicking out a new
movie every week yeah just about every
week There's a new Tom Hayne movie here
okay I don't know I don't know anything
I don't know anything anymore hey champ
time for the First YouTube comments of
2024 okay sounds good let's get into it
here's some YouTube comments uh of
course you know you're you're on the the
internet you know uh what was it show me
the rocket money Bad Bunny and uh you if
you share your comments that really uh
that's a really wonderful thing because
D is always reading them Chad and I are
always dipping in we got the Discord you
got even Instagram at dudy pod show
there's a bunch of comments there those
are social media
platforms hold on dude hold on dude hold
on
Chad hold on brother hold on Chad hold
on dude hold on all right let's get into
some comments wow you really froze there
yeah dude I'm really starting he doesn't
even pull out the um if I may as much
anymore
um this is from the captain Jupiter's
show oh
8624 he says okay these are all comments
from uh two weeks ago our dude's evening
special uh thank you so much to everyone
who tuned in we really covered the eight
ways of dude's evening it was a [__]
gas Chad and I were uh pretty Stoned on
some Gabus and we had a good time the
the captain Jupiter show 8624 says will
holding a blun blunt and a stout
coughing out the soul of a grizzly bear
with the double chin face about killed
me uh yeah I we were coughing a lot uh
this is from uh Kyler Kyler Newton 3498
says hey Will did you know that did you
know that when you cough straight into
the mic that goes right into our ears so
thanks for doing that yeah this guy
shares your opinion Chad what say you I
agree with my opinion and this guy's
opinion yeah don't I'm I'll try not to
cough as much that I think that's a I
think that's a good critique uh Kyler
Newton KY
Newton here watch
this what yeah what was that I don't
know dude hey you know it's never heard
anything like it yeah new me new 20 20
uh new year new me realistic coughing
yeah realistic coughing this is from
Chris French
806 66 uh I love how will I love how
will is fat baiting Chad for a bite of
his carrot cake you of course had your
carrot cake slab for your uh your way of
the [__] it your dude's evening snack I
was baiting you uh no will is fat
baiting
Chad what does that even mean for a for
a bite of his carrot cake these are
quotes of mine he's writing that looks
amazing I said uh I love carrot
cake did you say that [__] and I didn't
give you a bite I eat that whole [__]
thing pal yeah man you housed it uh I
believe is dud even I had to way the
[__] it we will put this is another
thing I said he says uh we will put
these down even though that looks
amazing dude that's so funny plus I
didn't even remember it plus he kept
looking at it he's claiming I was
looking at
you okay so that's so [__] funny yeah
he has a good point there I was really I
mean I I had two of my special baloney
uh and P of [__] American cheese like
[__] just [__] valita sandwiches what
two no that's true I had two during the
show and then uh third one was ready to
go and uh I did eat it uh right after
the show ended okay so there's that this
one's from Ryan Shelton 3142 dang Chad
give will a bite of that slab dude
sheesh everybody's [__] pissed at me
I didn't give you any the slab I'll give
you some slab next time dude no don't
tell don't tell my wonderful wife Molly
that you offered me carrot cake yeah I W
A lot of sugar on there okay Brandon
Brown uh 8370 said enjoying some TR TR
marijuana ah TR marijana I gu the way of
the [__] it Chad's got a carrot cake
slab Will's got the my rock is turning
into Jesse venturo right it's a carrot
cake slab The Rock Says carrot cake slab
doesn't matter okay enjoying some troan
and watching a new dudes Z makes for a
great dude's evening sadly enjoying it
alone cuz I've been at work all day and
stuck at work uh early in the morning
but I hope every pod palad dudy out
there has a chill and awesome dudes
evening Brandon Brown a chilling dude's
off uh chill dude's evening to you um a
chill belated dude's evening and that if
I may uh if I may that was what I really
enjoyed about the the dude's evening
special a couple weeks ago it really
felt like a chill hang with all of our
pods Brandon Brown in the immortal words
of Michael Jackson You Are Not
Alone hey Chad you're really you're a
good you're a good singer you're a good
singer I know yeah he's getting better
he's watching YouTube videos in our last
show of 2023 I asked both of you to
allow a complete stranger to ram a
camera into your [__] and check out
your colons for your first ever
colonoscopies will you please share your
results and your thoughts on the
experience as a whole this is colon boys
begin colon boys I mean just for anybody
out there who's thinking about getting a
colonoscopy a you should do it but B
they don't Ram a camera up your [__]
if they do I didn't feel it I was out
and so were you they may as well have
rammed a camera up my [__] I think
they slide it in you know there could be
some raming in there there's some stuff
in the way or you have a real tight in
the way tight pucker that day there
ain't no stuff in the way we can talk
about that dude well hold on dude you
had to drink that drink dude yeah dude
you got to drink some drink dude and
then you're [__] yellow water out of
your [__] for 24 hours dude yeah dude
it's called bile dude yeah dude and
that's a prep very colonoscopy also the
diet was crazy what' you think of the
diet leading into it uh the diet was
fine I had to not eat uh for a day you
you can have liquids you get a little
Jello-O did you enjoy some Jello-O some
chicken broth hell no what did you have
vegan guy what did you have water just
water all day for that day you're
allowed to eat some apples uh skinned
apples did you have that uh not on that
day yeah me neither I did not know that
I was eating bread pretty much cuz that
was allowed I bread was allowed yeah
okay this guy didn't tell everything uh
to me and now I'd like to Fat bait for
some of your bread and apples I didn't
realize that that was the uh that that
was the the way that went okay so we
both had these colonoscopies I do agree
with you Chad everyone out there if
you're around 40 go get a colonoscopy
and I'm here to tell you it was not a
scary experience it was actually
perfectly chill how was how did your
colonoscopy you know I hate needles I
hate hospitals and all that [__] and I
agree with you it was it was very mild
but definitely go get one like will said
if you're around 40 because instances of
colon cancer Are Climbing exponentially
and they're getting younger and younger
and younger the rates are all going up I
think because of the processed foods and
[__] I think it's processed food plastic
in the environment etc etc but all kinds
of cancers are going up but colon cancer
especially is getting really prevalent
in younger and younger demographics so
go get it checked out because here's the
deal all colon cancer starts out as a
pup in your colon all of it 100% of it
not all pops are cancerous but all
cancers start in those polyps so if you
go in and they find PPS they cut them
out and it absolves you of cancer it can
save your life literally you should
definitely go get it done yeah so um
let's talk
about uh pup count what do you got zero
nice clean real clean real clean hole
chat and uh oh there we are we're
looking
at this is a a selfie that I took uh
while I was waiting to go in dudes he's
pilfered your phone for this selfie of
you lovely uh there's a Chad ready to go
in for his [__] colonoscopy that was
the look that I had on my face when I
wheeled me in there too I was like ready
for my
colonoscopy I'm I'm stoked you have no
pops yeah good clean as a whistle so the
dude told me 10 years I'll probably go
back a little before that but if you got
no uh pups I guess that's what you got
what was your result my I'm happy to
tell you I had one pop it was a small
one though uh this is the way that it
that it works that as I've learned uh a
1 cm pop uh that's called that's that's
a problem uh that's where the the
pre-cancer can turn into more of cancer
um mine was 5 millim so half that when
you get to 10 millimet 1 cm that's uh
when you they cut it out they cut it out
sent it in for a biopsy they sented him
for a biopsy not cancerous congrats dude
that's great thank you very much I'm I'm
stoked I will go back um in 2 to three
years because it was pre I I should say
does this mean cancer is pre
cancerous um I mean possibly it depends
on what's in there you should call them
back and get if the dude told you you
don't have to come back then you're good
well he said you don't have to come back
for the next uh uh uh five years I would
like to do it again five years but he
also said you know if you came in in
three years wouldn't be a bad thing what
a [__] racket am I right dude it's a
conveyor belt they just line people at
least the place I went to they just line
[__] up roll you in camera up
the ass y Ki propal also by the way that
was my favorite part of it dude the prop
they give you some of that prop and uh
this is the drug that Michael Jackson
was murdered with this is a drug that
killed Prince and I got to say I kind of
get it Michael Jackson was having this
[__] injected nightly to sleep I don't
sleep that well if at all and this [__]
was
good you enjoyed it I awakened refresh
yeah yeah the
prop oh and there's me there's me right
before similar kind of pictures we took
some uh selfies it looks like I have
some sort of uh something on my chest
there to read my that's your bioport
dude yeah dude that hold on dude that's
how we figure out what's going on with
your heart dude um yeah I'm I look on my
face there here is is that of someone
who's uh dreaming of the polyps uh the
amount uh this is before I knew that it
was only uh one little tiny 5mm pup I am
so thankful so thankful of that you know
I was going to say when I woke up I woke
up from the thing completely completely
awake uh my doctor was there you know
kind of hey Will and Molly was there uh
and he goes you're done and I literally
was like get the [__] out of here yeah
and I time is lost time is completely
lost like I went bye-bye as I was
sitting there ready to go and we I was
joking around with all the you know the
nurses and the and the fella and uh by
fella I mean doctor and and then I woke
up and I was reminded of when um this is
over 20 years ago now we've I've talked
about it on the show I lost 200 lbs in
the year 1999 to to 2000 hey I missed
that last 50 so I gained it back kept it
on for the past 20
years all right and um I had two
surgeries I lost the [__] out of 200 lb
eating completely clean I had a trainer
who changed my life um and um I was able
to I was a young guy I was 24 and I
dropped all this weight I had two
surgeries to remove skin one from um I
had the appendectomy where they had to
cut off my [__] panis of skin choppy
floppity uh beef meat [__] Loop and
then uh move my belly button up and then
move my nips up a bit and cut off my
[__] Abdullah the Butcher side tit my
big [__] meaty slab a side tit yeah
and then um uh when I woke up this is
crazy crazy when I woke
up when I woke up from my first
surgery hire by Creed was playing it it
just came out it was the year 2000 and
when I woke up from my second surgery
six weeks later uh to do my um was it
six weeks I believe so to do my yeah I
looked like this and I woke up and uh
Creed was playing higher same song the
exact same song wow yeah so that's a fun
uh memory from that but at any did you
wake up from this colonoscopy and have
Creed no that's why I was bummed that
there was noed Arms Wide Open
yeah you got to lock your jaw more close
close your teeth
completely um so uh yeah I I'm stoked I
did it and me too overall a fun
experience I think yeah it was a fun
experience go out and get your that prob
dude what is going on I can't stop
thinking about the prop it was just so
good I just I mean like you said the
time is lost you don't you're not like
dreaming during it or anything but
coming out of it I was just like [__]
how long was I out felt like I slept for
a week but it was like 20 minutes or
something yeah uh it was great and I
tried to fight it I've had a couple of
surgeries in my life and I always try to
fight the anesthetic to really uh
experience the moment that you're
blacking out and this one was hard it
was the hardest fight that I've ever had
I was looking forward to a nice dreamy
sleep a camera being shoved up my ass
and waking up to the sweet sounds of
Scott St but uh alas I didn't uh I
didn't get to hear that but oh there I
am uh again and uh go get your go get
yeah get it done get your colonoscopy
get it just get it done you don't want
to you do not want to be looking back
after 40 going I should have got that
done so please all of our P can
literally save your life it's like will
had a had a p up in there he doesn't get
the colonoscopy he goes another 5 years
without it who the [__] knows what that
thing becomes and then you're looking at
colon cancer which is chemotherapy
radiation possibly some [__]
surgeries and you don't want to be in
that situation and you can avoid it by
just going to get this little thing done
you get that sweet prop loves the prop
I'll tell you I'll tell you another
thing uh I'll throw in some more vegan
Gru during the week yeah dude you know
that's why you got the pup you're
talking about these riye steaks and [__]
yeah whatever I have a steak every once
in a while with a completely
carcinogenic charcoal blackened outside
exactly is that doing something to my
just eating charcoal bricketts out of a
[__] barbecue I will say that oh
thank you moving on never mind plenty
more colon talk and dudy after
dudy yeah will we all know you're a
wrestling purist you don't watch movies
with wrestlers attempting to act and you
don't watch movies about wrestling
because you prefer the in quotes real
thing we get it but you did manage to
see the iron claw during the break
starring Zack Efron Jeremy Allen White
Lily James and Harris Dickinson and Chad
you saw it too I'm so curious to hear
what you both thought of this movie This
is the Imp purest the ironclaw begin
interesting not an assignment to watch
the movie and yet there's no way either
of us would have missed right ly did you
see it with Molly yeah did you see it
with Laura I did okay was Molly crying
at the end of it she was so was Laura
were you I was not crying at the end of
the movie I know I know the story well
my reason for not crying is different
than
yours what's mine I don't know let's
talk about it why didn't you cry uh
emotionally distant and abusive father
that's what I was going to say yep so
anyway
um yeah the iron claw speaking of
emotionally abusive and distant father
Fritz Von Eric that was my dad
basically you know pretty much it's um
this movie if you haven't uh heard of
the ironclaw is of course the story of
the von Eric Brothers the wrestling
Dynasty uh that that Fritz Von Eric a
wrestler in the what the 1960s and 50s
uh you know a wrestler who took over a
territory in Texas and ended up uh with
having he had five boys the story is
tragic please go watch the story as a
matter of fact I'll skip everything
about the Von Erics I know that a lot of
people know about this movie because
it's a big movie staring Zack Efron
Jeremy Allen White Harris Dickinson uh
but go out and watch the vice
documentary from their dark side the
ring series and watch the Von Erics one
it's incredible so this is a movie that
had has a very there's a very sad story
that goes along with the Von Erics all
but one of these um five brothers has
passed on uh six brothers what am I
saying because there was seven
technically yeah Jackie died at the age
of five then David uh passed away then
Mike got into it and he passed away then
uh then Chris passed away uh who is not
even in the
movie then Carrie and the remaining one
is uh Kevin there and there was even
another one what do you mean well they
later conscripted someone to be another
von Eric brother he was a cousin that
was Lance von Eric he wasn't a brother
he was a cousin my apologies played by
Maxwell Jacob fredman in the movie most
of it being cut out we're talking of
course yeah about uh but I agree with
you that they they did not have Chris
von Eric in here which I thought was a
strange Choice um for me it was a good
movie overall this is a good movie it's
a good movie and the bottom line is this
I think that a lot of people are talking
about Zack a afron's going to get an
Oscar nomination for this if that
happens did he get a golden Global Nom
nomination or is this movie came out too
late I don't think yeah I think this
whole movie is too late I don't think
it's I think so too so be next year but
if he gets an Oscar nomination that
means this is going to be an Oscar
nominated movie about the real pro
wrestlers I think it's going to explode
into a sub genre and you're going to see
these types of movies made about a bunch
of like the real life stories of various
pro wrestlers look I'll I'll watch I'll
watch all of that I will become less of
a I'll become less pure uh I will I will
uh as far as my my um digestion of uh
fictitious uh wrestling not to be
confused with real wrestling which is
what this movie is about now you know
what I mean by real specifically uh to
that point I want to say that you know
Fritz Von Eric in this movie the actor
that played Fritz Von Eric uh Holt
malleny was Unreal as Fritz Von Eric he
even looked like him his body is that of
Fritz Von Erics he has
now okay look here's what I want to
say I am the Imp purist I love wrestling
it is the one of the greatest art form
forms uh I am proud to hold this title
which is not a wrestling title uh but it
is the dudy episode championship and I I
hold on to it with the much love that I
have for the 10 pounds of nickel and and
here's what I want to say this this
movie there's a part in the movie
there's a lot of things I could say as a
wrestling fan but there's a part in the
movie where uh where Fritz Von Eric says
to the boys or says to uh Kevin or
Carrie I believe he says you know well
you got you know you got taken in that
last week we're going to have to see
what you can do this week get out there
and get your get your payback and it's
like uh we know that the I thought it
was interesting of the filmmaker to sort
of play with kayfabe there um you know
have it sort of that it's that it's real
but he explains it the Zack Efron
character explains it to the woman that
would become his wife ultimately cuz she
even asks him there's a scene where
they're sitting down to dinner and the
early in their courtship and she's like
well it's all fake ain't it and he's
like look let me explain to you like
this being the World Heavyweight
Champion is like being the CEO it's like
the highest honor you can get and that
means you're the best guy doing it at
that time and I thought that was a good
explanation because it's not about like
it's a reward yeah is the the thing
staged or not is the outcome stage of
course but it's like who can play those
staged outcomes the best gets to be the
Champion by that logic I'm sure yeah I
think it makes sense that I mean
whatever there's a lot of stuff in the
movie that as a wrestling purist I was a
little bit I couldn't fit my [__]
head around it yeah you know look look
let me just say let me just say out loud
Carrie von Eric the star of the family
according to Fritz his favorite that
[__] was 63 260 250 270
something like that he was an Adonis he
looked he looked like John Travolta in
the face this ridiculous [__] body
the guy was stacked upon stacked what's
funny nothing I'm just smiling listening
to you en Joy talking about the body of
your favorite PR wrestler or whatever it
was it he was [__] unbelievable he
had that Curly [__] hair the ' 80s
thing the women loved this guy him and
Kevin and and David would come down the
aisle you know in the old wccw at the
sportatorium which by the way they
recreated the sportatorium this is what
I mean by urist that part actually Molly
was like that part really struck you
when I saw the sportatorium and it's a
real shot it's not CGI they built the
[__] thing in Louisiana uh you know
it's in Texas obviously and it's gone
but they rebuilt this [__] thing it
it was unbelievable but I got to say if
you were going to design a pro wrestler
it's Carrie von Eric um played by Jeremy
Allen White in the movie now look Carrie
von Eric 6'3 Jeremy Allen White's like
5758 if you don't know anything about
that if you don't know things to the
degree that a that a big wrestling fan
like me knows it's a wonderful movie I
love Jeremy Allen White Harris Dickinson
is fast becoming my favorite actor right
now of like new actors he's he's
fantastic he does an incredible job at
David but David was like a big son of a
[__] like a Barry Windham extremely uh
extremely mobile for a big man he had
the mechanics Kevin von Eric he had an
extremely athletic body catlike catlike
yeah he just [__] catlike mikee von
Eric yeah you know you could tell with
with maybe some more training and stuff
he would have uh he looked a lot like
Kevin was was a little shorter uh and a
lot smaller um but he was an incredible
athlete still a pretty good body yeah
yeah and I and I think that um you know
I just kind of feel like in the movie
The you know the the the Stanley Simons
did a wonderful job as as Mike Fon Eric
it was so gripping he was so troubled um
but you know it's just hard for me to
get around the illusion you know what I
mean I agree with you there cuz there
were for me in the um the scenes where
they're actually wrestling right that
[__] was like hard to buy cuz like
you're saying Jeremy Allen White is like
kind of a tiny dude and the Von Erics
were all these kind of like giants they
they were they were mythical all of
course except for Young Chris von Eric
who also they all passed away they all I
mean David it was a there's some
whatever Watch the documentary I'm
talking about on the the vice dark side
of the ring you'll learn about David but
you know Mike committed suicide Chris
committed suicide then Terry committed
suicide um Chris von Eric was the run to
the litter um but was like from what I
understand a very funny kid definitely
had a future in the business had he
stuck around there's a lot more things
you can do besides you know in being an
in ring performer and uh Chris von Eric
was not built like um was not built like
his brothers Lance von Eric doesn't
count he's not a von Eric sure but if we
talk about that Family the the they were
they were physically um they were such
an interesting group and and I think
it's hard to to mimic that in in the
show uh in the movie look a lot of
things they couldn't put in the movie
what do you want you want a [__]
miniseries you want a 4our movie yeah
they could have done that but I mean
look the as I said before and still
maintain this the bottom line is there
might have been some discrepancies
between what really happened obviously
leaving out an entire [__] brother
that is like a little weird to me the
bodies may not match up all this [__]
but I think that this is like good
overall for wrestling because it now
paints wrestling as something that is
like Oscar worthy you know guy that's
wonderful to hear you say that yeah yeah
I'll tell you who's not getting any uh
nominations of anyway the guy who
[__] played Ric Flair
dude as soon as that guy came on screen
I was like what in the [__] is Will
thinking watching this oh my God so
listen I don't know who the gentleman is
I'm sure he's a wonderful actor it's a
tall order I can tell I I would be
willing to bet that he was not familiar
with Ric Flair before the movie was made
or was enough to convince them to give
him the role that's what it seemed like
to me like I love Ric Flair I can do
this please I know everything about him
they like great get in there physically
he looked nothing like Rick Ric Flair at
all it was the wrong choice at Le he
sounded just like him right uh no he
didn't sound anything like him um the
promo was all over the place it's just
those things that in order for everyone
to buy the illusion I'm just going to
speak for wrestling fans the Ric Flair
was was as Stone Cold would say the
drizzling shits I didn't get it and I
and also the [__] perfect Ric Flair
is waiting to be cast and his name is
Jay Lethal do you know who Jay Lethal is
to some degree okay Jay Lethal is a is a
I always have to figure like what kind
of wrestling knowledge does this guy
have at this point over here but growing
yeah it's growing it's definitely
growing you have a favorite wrestler now
hangman Adam pige and I have his rookie
card yeah you have his rookie card but
Jay Lethal uh who uh is now sort of
floating in and out of well he's with
aew and Ring of Honor and uh he's
incredible he's one of my favorites
really truly a guy I mentioned during
dude's evening is having the best
Macho Man impression it goes It goes Jay
Lethal then it goes Dan Soder and then I
don't know maybe a couple of one or two
sure I'll throw here come on everybody
let's have a good time you know it's
dudy after
all hold on hold
on hold on uh yeah didn't really care
for the Ric Flair no uh didn't have much
of the Cadence there wasn't quite
exactly a Ric Flair oh no it wasn't no
he had the wrong eye color let's start
there cast the right actor with the
right uh you want talk you want dudes
yeah you want to talk about intonation
yeah you want to talk about flexing your
vocal cords yeah you want to talk about
uh creating an illusion yeah a mirage on
the distance yeah the Horizon the iron
claw yeah lots of fiction happening in
the movie yeah to make it fit an hour
and a half 2 hours that's about as long
as you want you don't want to do that
con Festival 4H hour movie get booed
right out of France no no you want the
movie to come together right yeah and
you could have done a lot better with
that Ric Flair yeah get Jay Leal he
looks and sounds just like Ric Flair
more than that other guy and if
you
okay that wasn't performative anyway go
see the [__] uh movie holy [__] it
really was a [__] spectacle that some
of the stuff was so beautiful and 1980s
and it was just like it was a one it's a
wonderful movie it's a different thing
if you're um a purist like me um and uh
I don't know I don't know what else to
say I love I love the Von Erics I've
always loved the Von Erics
I love Carrie von Eric and his big huge
muscular body and and I love Kevin Von
Eric's body thank you moving on and
David Von Eric's body yeah and Mike Von
Eric's Body And even Chris voner and
Fritz Von Eric's body yeah Fritz that
that guy who played Fritz Von Eric he I
I don't know much about him as all right
anyway all right you like their bodies I
like their bodies yeah wowe what a way
to start off the new year episode 87 set
the bar pretty godamn high you scored 99
points today I'll add them to your total
which brings you to
8,176 overall points you only have to
get
1,824 more points before 10K we're
getting close we are next week I want
you boys to kick off Awards season by
watching the very first MTV video music
awards from 1984 it's been 40 years
since that groundbreaking awards show
and I'll make the watch along available
on dudy Plus at patreon.com / dudy this
Friday at noon Pacific thanks to
everyone for joining us this week I'm
going to absorb what we did here today
to make next week even better until then
call me dudy holy [__] that's going to
be cool dude yeah that is going to be
cool the 1984 Video Music Awards can't
believe it's been 40 years I know um if
if you are not uh with us on dudy plus
patreon.com dudy 7 bucks a month gets
you everything that we do including some
pretty [__] weird watch alongs and
you don't need to queue anything up or
whatever it's all going to be there
Friday at noon we're going to watch you
want to smoke some gabis and watch the
video music awards of course sounds like
a good time hey come you know hang
around it's dudy after dudy pretty
shortly we're going to talk about Ric
Flair and our colins and Cat Williams
and all sorts of [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] hey here it comes Cannonball
coming you know it's dudy after dudy
it's that part of the show where [__]
chills out and if you want to continue
to hang with us and it's going to be a
hell of a [__] hang lots to talk
about today head over to patreon.com
dudy join dudy plus and just keep a
[__] go and you watch the watch the
whole show because it's uh the mood's a
little different mhm things get a little
blue literally figurativ it's a little
more intimate yeah we might spark up
some gabis and I am looking forward to
this episode of dudy after dudy and I am
looking forward to that watch Along on
Friday yeah insane I really missed doing
the show with you both last week I
missed it so much I actually felt sad
and now I feel happy as hell to be back
at it with you for another episode and
another dudy after dudy the flagship
weekly show of dudy plus only at
patreon.com dudy and now I have the
unenviable job of figuring out who won
today's show and therefore who is going
to walk away with the belt you boys
behave while I'm gone this is dudy after
dudy Stand and
Deliver all right let's Stand and
Deliver it who's going to walk away with
the belt look dude I'll tell you this
about the belt if if you don't know dudy
after dudy is where that is determined
who gets to wear the championship belt
which will currently is
wearing I'm just going to say
this you're going to win it today
probably I think what the [__] you but
in the very near future I'm going to win
it I'm GNA call my shot one day and I'm
just gonna [__] take it how would how
would you know that I don't think you
could know that I know that
because if you like d here what you
do please tell a friend then
R if you like Dy
here
please tell then